you need to be obsessive because
look if you're happy to come into
recruitment and you know earn 50 60 70
80k a year you know that's fine but you
know you can do that by just probably
plodding along doing the average numbers
you know and just and just just about
hitting target but
if you really want to be the best of the
best and you want to be the best in the
industry you need to be obsessed you
have to be because
you know
you don't get to the top of your game by
being lucky and by being lazy and being
average you really need to be obsessed
of getting to the top and
also as well i think you need to sort of
realize that the journey never ends
um i think a lot of people think oh you
know once i get here that's me i'm done
i'm happy the goal post always moves and
i think you need to be in a mentality
where you understand that you know in my
head i was like okay once i get to 50k a
week that's a good good target once i've
got there i'm like let's get 60.
now i've got today i'm like let's get to
70. so i think you need to have an
endless appetite i think you need to
just want to achieve and achieve and
achieve
and discipline that's that's the key
thing
you know i won't say you need to be good
on the phone you need to be a great
salesman of course it's great it's
important but like i said hard work
beats talent um you need to be
disciplined if you if you have the right
mentality and you you follow the right
process and you're consistent and you
stick to it you will achieve results and
i think if you've got that kind of
attitude and that kind of
focus i think you will be a successful
contract recruiter 100
the recruitment mentors podcast is
proudly sponsored by vincerie and the
award-winning sauce breaker